je
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sociétés l'émission de la rédaction
pour débattre discuter et réfléchir sur
les grands enjeux qui touchent notre
environnement nos vies et qui font aussi
l'actualité l'environnement il en sera
d'ailleurs largement question durant
cette émission puisque nous allons voir
comment les collectivités territoriales
peuvent lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
tout le monde connaît forcément les
accords internationaux qui fixent le
cadre pour limiter ce réchauffement
climatique on pense évidemment à la coop
21 mai on s'est beaucoup moins aussi que
les collectivités se dote d'outils pour
réduire par exemple leurs émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'ici la fin de
l'année l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines sera dotée d'un pc à eux tu
es un plan climat air énergie
territorial de quoi il s'agit quels sont
ses objectifs ses conséquences pour les
citoyens les entreprises les
associations locales nous allons
discuter avec nos invités autour de la
table bertrand houillon vice président
de saint quentin en yvelines en charge
du développement durable notamment
véronique houssin responsable du projet
pc a été pour saint quentin en yvelines
et enfin jean-paul vanderlinden
professeur à lui vécu et membre de
l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi bon soir
et bonjour à tous les trois avant
d'évoquer ce sujet climatique je vous
propose de regarder plusieurs modules et
quelques minutes en lien avec notre
thématique et qui permettront de mieux
cerner les effets du réchauffement
climatique ses impacts et les moyens
aussi mises en place pour lutter contre
regarder
[Musique]
nature et galles futur
des fourmis bien orienté ces fourmis qui
vont et viennent sont à la recherche de
nourriture
elles sont un peu comme des têtes
chercheuses qui explore de nombreux
chemins dans tous les sens puis
retournent vers leurs colonies à
première vue tout cela semble très
désordonnée mais en vérité ces fourmis
communiquent ensemble de façon très
intelligente afin d'optimiser leurs
déplacements ces méthodes d'optimisation
ne pourrait-elle pas être utile à nos
propres déplacements chez les fourmis il
ya une division de des tâches et donc
que certaines fourmis qui vont
participer à la recherche de nourriture
et ces fourmis qui sortent à l'extérieur
du nid on les appelle des fous rageuse
vous pouvez tout à fait tomber sur une
fourmi tout seul qui va partir dans
différentes directions dans l'impression
ne sait pas où elle va et c'est vrai
elle sait pas où elle va elle est en
train de chercher de la nourriture mais
se trouvent de la nourriture
elle peut repartir en suivant le chemin
qu'elle a suivi au départ et là elle va
poser sur le sol des ferments non alors
les fermes en sont les substances
chimiques qui servent à la communication
entre les individus
et ça ça également à recruter des
congénères dans la colonie pour qu'elle
sache où se trouve la source de
nourriture
si on prend le chemin un long et un
cours une fourmi va mettre plus de temps
à faire le trajet le plus long donc si
on prend laps de temps donné et il est
clair que le chemin le plus court aura
vu beaucoup plus de passage de fourmi
que le chemin le plus long
et comme à chaque fois la fourmi va
marquer la piste est bien au bout d'un
certain temps il y aura beaucoup plus de
marques chimiques sur le chemin le plus
court que sur le chemin le plus long
voilà on va parler d'intelligence
collective parce que typiquement cas
elle prend la piste elle ne sait pas que
c'est le chemin le plus court
elle tout ce qu'elle sait c'est que
c'est le chemin qui sont le plus fort
parce qu'il ya le plus de phéromones sur
la piste
cette intelligence collective qui permet
à la colonie de fourmis d'accéder plus
rapidement à une source de nourriture
est aussi appelée intelligence on est
sain
eh bien les chercheurs à la fois
informaticien et mathématiciens ont
commencé à s'intéresser aux
comportements collectifs des fourmis
dans les années 90 essentiellement en
étudiant leur comportement pour en tirer
des algorithmes d'optimisation un
algorithme d'optimisation n'est pas une
équation mathématique c'est un ensemble
de règles qu'on va donner un ordinateur
pour qu'il exécute toute une série de
tâches qui vont aboutir à trouver une
solution optimale
l'algorithme de colonies de fourmis
fonctionne sur une imitation du
comportement des fourmis ses algorithmes
d'optimisation ont tout d'abord été
utilisé pour résoudre ce qu'on appelle
des problèmes de chemin au petit mot
dans un graff c'est à dire trouver le
chemin le plus court qui relie des
points entre eux ce type d'algorithmes
est utilisée lorsque le nombre de
possibilités est astronomique et qu'il
serait hors de question d'essayer de les
tester une par une
parmi les applications très élaborée de
cet algorithme il y en a une que de
nombreuses personnes utilisent
quotidiennement sans le savoir
c'est le gps c'est donc grâce aux
fourmis que nous arrivons à nous
déplacer de façon optimale
nous avons tout d'abord commencé à
travailler dans tout ce qui concerne
l'optimisation de routage en général
c'est à dire de chemins les plus courts
pour organiser soi
la collecte des déchets soit la
distribution du courrier sur une tournée
de collecte des déchets ou par exemple
il nécessaire de faire sans tourner nous
prenons en compte toutes les contraintes
de collecte mono latéral bilatérales
d'utilisation de type de camion
différent de nécessité d'aller vider le
camion quand celui ci est plein pour
être mises dans le logiciel est ensuite
être optimisé par rapport à sa tombe de
critères qui sont essentiellement la
durée de la de la collecte et le nombre
de kilomètres parcourus et bien grâce à
l'utilisation de notre logiciel et de ce
type d'algorithmes on peut économiser
entre 10 et 20 tournées c'est à dire dix
et vingt équipes et 10 et 20 camions
ce gain économique s'accompagne de plus
d'un gain écologique
nous avons donc un impact à la fois sur
la consommation de carburant mais
également sur le taux d'émission des gaz
à effet de serre qui dit
grandement par le moindre nombre de
camions et par le moindre nombre de
kilomètres parcourus
ce qui est bien évidemment non
négligeable quand il s'agit d'optimiser
les choses pour une collectivité locale
par exemple les sociétés d'insectes ont
une capacité à résoudre d'une manière
très souple des problèmes quotidiens
très variés et nombreux
les abeilles les termites fournissent
elles aussi d'autres modèle
d'intelligence collective pour concevoir
des algorithmes d'optimisation et on
peut même s'inspirer du fonctionnement
des organismes biologiques pour mettre
au point des algorithmes à biomimétique
[Musique]
nature et galles futur des ailes dans la
ville quand nous observons des insectes
volet nous ne faisons pas vraiment
attention à la précision et à la qualité
du battement de leurs ailes car nous ne
les voyons pas en détail pourtant en les
observant au ralenti on réalise à quel
point ses ailes se déforme sous l'effet
du battement quelles sont les forces en
jeu entre ces structures et les milieux
environnants et comment pourrait-on
adapter une telle capacité de
flexibilité et de déformation en filmant
ces insectes ou typiquement des
papillons des libellules
là on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait des
grandes déformations dans les ailes qui
vraisemblablement les aider à faux les
dlc ce pas l'objet régime et donc on
sait qu'il ya une interaction entre
élasticité de l'objet et la dynamique
depuis le tour pour reproduire en
laboratoire le vol de ces insectes et
l'étudier on a créé des insectes
mécaniques donc des gros insecte qu'on a
fait voler entre guillemets en
laboratoire et en reproduisant
d'élasticité des ailes par un matériau
qu'on connaît bien et qu'on peut bien
caractérisée a cependant on peut faire
des vraies mesures sur des insectes qui
sont autopropulsés mais mécanique sur
l'insecte mécanique lui même nous avons
des ailes des différentes activités donc
cdl un plastique dont on peut faire
varier l'épaisseur elle des différentes
épaisseurs vont nous donner différents
rigidité et en variant la fréquence du
moteur ont fait battre
la différence fréquences je confesse est
installée la sec mécanique dans un
manège qui tourne à une vitesse de
croisière
on a essentiellement travaillé sur la
déformation des ailes à quel point les
ailes sous des formes sous l'effet du
fluide environnants cette équipe de
chercheurs a réussi à analyser les
nombreux paramètres des battements
d'aile d'insectes et à les traduire en
équation mathématique uniquement en
déformant leur zèle sous l'effet du
fluide environnant les insectes peuvent
économiser jusqu'à 50% d'énergie avec un
mécanisme qui est complètement passifs
ça qu'on le sent que ça leur coûte quoi
que ce soit on a fait la démonstration
que si vous vous pliez vos ailes pendant
que vous êtes en train de voler vous
avez un profil qui est plus
aérodynamique et qui s'adapte tout le
temps aux turbulences qui son retour et
en faisant ça ou le dissiper de
l'énergie dans le fluide on la garde
pour soi elle me permet d'avancer
c'est comme ça qu'on économise de
l'énergie cette capacité de stockage de
l'énergie grâce à une plus grande
flexibilité peut avoir de nombreuses
applications de la recherche ou les
insectes et mais une nouvelle recherche
sur les éoliennes a pas le flexible on
s'inspire directement des travaux qu'on
a fait sur les encerclent le vent qui
vient frapper l'éolienne pour la faire
tourner va déformer la pâle et parce que
la pâle se déforme les performances vont
être améliorés ce laboratoire de
physique collabore avec des élèves de
l'école nationale supérieure de création
industrielle afin de développer des
éoliennes mills adapté au vent on
travaille en plein dans la main d'un
côté scientifique et technique et
l'autre côté un côté de d'insertion dans
le tissu urbain de ces nouveaux objets
les idées qu'ont émergé c'est par
exemple le mobilier urbain dans
typiquement se servir des éoliennes pour
alimenter des lampadaires
on espère très bientôt pour fois faire
des prototypes et puis après pourquoi
pas une commercialisation pour l'éolien
personnel
par vent faible les éoliennes classiques
ne fonctionnent pas il faut modifier
leurs angles en fonction de la vitesse
du vent et de sa direction
si au contraire les pales d'une éolienne
s'adapte au régime du vent en se
déformant
on pourra toujours récupérer de
l'énergie
on peut donc imaginer demain 2 min 01
yens installés dans nos rues ou sur nos
balcons qui fournirait une électricité
naturel aux particuliers et aux
collectivités
oui
[Musique]
savez vous qu'il existe un lien
entre ce champ de blé et ce futur
bâtiment
[Musique]
entre nos forêts et l'isolation de cette
maison souvient ce sont les matériaux
biosourcés
[Musique]
mais en fait c'est pas en matériaux
biosourcés il existe une définition
réglementaire qui est issue du label
bâtiment de source et qui dit qu'un
matériau de source et est issue de la
biomasse animales ou végétales
ces matériaux ils sont issus soit de
l'agriculture de la sylviculture ou du
recyclage s'appelle des aussi des
matières recyclées une petite précision
quand celle de l'agriculture en fait
c'est des coûts produits agricoles terre
qu'on n'utilise pas la partie de la
plante qui dédie à l'alimentaire on
utilise vraiment la partie qui
aujourd'hui moins valorisés ou ou pas
valoriser les matériaux biosourcés on
les utilise beaucoup pour le bâtiment il
ya vraiment une grande diversité de
produits d'application possible sur le
territoire français par contre il ya
plein d'autres applications notamment
dans la plasturgie dans l'automobile
dans la cosmétique dans la
pharmaceutique on peut les trouver dans
la chimie du végétal
il ya vraiment une
une valorisation de toutes les parties
de la plante en coproduisant
sous-produits de
des végétaux dans ces matériaux donc on
a essentiellement trois catégories ont
utilisé un peu partout dans le bâtiment
à la fois en gros oeuvre en second
oeuvre en finition un projet bio sourcés
est il compliqué à réaliser un projet à
base de matériaux biosourcés n'est pas
nécessairement plus compliqué à réaliser
qu'un bâtiment traditionnel réalisé avec
des méthodes contemporaine de
construction ou de réhabilitation c'est
compliqué dans le sens où il faut faire
attention à des aspects technologiques
importants comme par exemple
l'étanchéité à l'air c'est un point sur
lequel on ne peut pas déroger mais quand
soit en conventionnel ou en matériaux
biosourcés on va avoir exactement les
mêmes les mêmes problèmes donc oui c'est
compliqué mais pas plus quand on utilise
un matériau qui ne soient bio sourcées
ou pas il faut prendre en compte ces
caractéristiques thermiques hydrique etc
il faut adapter la conception et la mise
en oeuvre en fonction des matériaux
qu'on utilise
je crois qu on est plutôt dans des
techniques qui sont innovantes que dans
des anciennes techniques si ce n'est
quand on en parle sur le bâti ancien
pour les enduits chaux chanvre par
exemple qui font appel finalement même
technique que les enduits l'isolation
par l'extérieur comme on peut le voir
ici on est sur des techniques
contemporaines avec une ossature bois un
bardage bois et puis un isolant dessous
que l'isolant soit une laine minérale ou
une laine bio sourcés on va utiliser la
même la même technique c'est plus le
choix environnemental d'aller vers des
matériaux biosourcés qui va être
important quant à la technique non on ne
régresse pas au contraire on progresse
quels sont les atouts des matériaux
[Musique]
les matériaux biosourcés sont un des
moyens de réduire l'empreinte
environnementale des bâtiments
d'abord ce sont des matériaux
renouvelables à l'échelle de la durée de
vie du bâtiment parce que ce sont des
matériaux qui ont besoin de peu
d'énergie au cours de leur
transformation de leur mise en oeuvre
pour l'essentiel est surtout parce que
on sait que ces matériaux vont stocker
du carbone lors de la croissance des
végétaux et donc vont stocker du carbone
dans le bâtiment tout au long de la
durée de vie du bâtiment alors les
matériaux biosourcés sont pour moi les
seuls adapté au bâti ancien parce qu'il
respecte une caractéristique
fondamentale du bâti ancien qui et
l'hygrométrie dans un bâti fait de terre
et de pierres il y à des transferts de
vapeur d'eau et les matériaux biosourcés
qui sont hygroscopique vont se charger
en vapeur d'eau vont la redonner à
l'intérieur de la pièce ou à l'extérieur
et permettront ainsi en fonctionnement
qu'on appelle hygrothermique du bâtiment
qui est particulièrement intéressant
pour améliorer le confort thermique du
bâtiment en hiver et surtout pour
respecter le confort d'été du bâtiment
qui si on l'isolé trop va perdre sa
valeur fondamentale d'inertie qui permet
en fait le confort d'été alors
l'utilisation des matériaux biosourcés
est venu assez naturellement pour nous à
partir de des questions de préservation
du bâti ancien mais j'ai d'abord
travaillé pendant les premières années
où j'étais au parc appartient le
matériau que j'appelle le giro sur c
c'est à dire de la chaux de la terre la
pierre
et puis du bois bien sûr qui composent
une grande partie de ses maisons
anciennes
quand on s'est posés plus précisément
les questions d'isolation de ses
bâtiments
les matériaux biosourcés sont apparus
petit à petit comme une évidence
on savait très bien depuis le départ que
les laines minérales de façon générale
ne convenait pas pour cette isolation et
donc on a utilisé les matériaux
biosourcés quelle est la place
le bio sourcés dans la construction et
la réhabilitation de nos bâtiments alors
entre neuf et ancien aujourd'hui a pas
deux il ya pas de spécificité en fait à
des matériaux biosourcés qu'on va être
très intéressant pour l'ancien qui vont
avoir des caractéristiques de régulation
de l'humidité de confort qui sont très
intéressantes et on a aussi des
matériaux qui s'entraînait utilisant
deneuve y en a à chaque fois des
solutions qui sont différentes mais qui
sont adaptés et à la rénovation et au 9
s'est adapté au bâti notamment des
années 60 70 80
ça permet en les isolant par l'extérieur
d'atteindre niveau de rénovation
thermique très intéressant c'est aussi
un choix environnemental et
architectural qui permet de relooker ses
maisons quand un paquet cadeau dans une
isolation qui va être ici de la laine de
bois qui est intéressante pour le
déphasage pour renforcer l'inertie de la
maison et le confort d'été
et puis de faire un bardage bois qui
fait une seconde peau qui est aussi un
matériaux biosourcés on a tendance à
l'oublier quand on parle de matériaux
biosourcés s'est pas seulement les
isolants mais aussi le bois qui va
renforcer l'isolation elle même de la
maison
quelles sont les précautions à prendre
avec ces matériaux de construction les
principales pathologies qu'on va
rencontrer pour les matériaux bio
sorcier c'est la sensibilité à
l'humidité et le risque incendie
donc au niveau de la sensibilité à
l'humidité on va l'avoir à deux moments
va la voir en phase chantier où là il
faut être attentif à la manutention au
stockage et à la mise en oeuvre de
protéger les bio sourcés de toute source
d'humidité et puis aussi pendant la vie
du bâtiment pendant l'occupation du
bâtiment il faut être attentif aux
dégâts des eaux au niveau de la
sensibilité à lincent dit on a aussi d
une attention particulière apportée
pendant la mise en oeuvre notamment de
l'interface entre chantiers où on peut
avoir utilisation de chalumeau dans le
cadre d'une étanchéité à faire par
exemple et ne pas être attentif à ne pas
mettre une flamme chaude donc en contact
d'un matériaux biosourcés et puis
pendant la durée de vie du bâtiment il
faut aussi être attentif aux risques
d'incendiés dus à des échauffements qui
peuvent être dues à des sources de
chaleur dont soit par exemple des spots
électriques ou des conduits de fumée
pour mettre un produit
marcher est disponible sur le marché on
va devoir justifier de ses performances
et encore une fois passé à travers
l'arrêté de résistance au feu qui offre
différentes possibilités
donc ça on aura la capacité à justifier
de sa performance à travers des
approches de calcul ou bien ils nous
devrons passer par une justification
expérimental et réaliser des essais
conventionnel dans le bâtiment des
risques existent comme le développement
de moisissures ou encore la diminution
de la résistance physique
quels conseils donner pour les éditions
commuée de rechercher les règles de
l'art qui s'y réfèrent donc vous pouvez
soit avoir dnf dtu soit des
recommandations professionnelles rage
soit des règles professionnelles
acceptée par la cdp donc par exemple en
règles professionnelles pour les
matériaux biosourcés vous avez la
construction en paille remplissage
isolant et support ennuis où vous avez
également les exécutions ouvrages en
béton de chambre qu'il ya deux notions
clés dans la réglementation incendie
d'une part la réaction feu et d'autre
part la résistance au feu la réaction
feu sait plus ce qui va permettre de
classer la manade thériault pour dire
leur capacité à propager l'incendié et a
contribué en fait au développement du
feu l'autre notion c'est la résistance
au feu qui va toucher le forage est en
fait sa capacité à maintenir sa fonction
soit une fonction porteuses comme un mur
porteur un poteau et c soit une fonction
d'étanchéité au gaz ou encore une
fonction d'isolation c'est à dire pour
une paroisse un compartiment c
l'élévation de la température de côté la
face non exposés sont trois critères qui
permettent de répondre à la résistance
au feu la réglementation incendie
n'était elle pas plus compliqué à
respecter la réglementation incendie
n'est pas plus compliqué à respecter
avec les matériaux biosourcés à partir
du moment où on a les éléments de preuve
réglementaire à savoir les excès
conventionnel qui sont décrits dans les
arrêtés de résistance au feu
quel est le rôle de bêta pour réaliser
un une bonne acv d'un bâtiment il est
important de disposer de données fiables
de données précises qu'on appelle les
données environnementales qui permet de
faire des calculs alors au niveau des
batteurs ressources et il est certain
qu'il est nécessaire de monter en
puissance sur la production de ces
données environnementales de préciser
aussi les scénarios de fin de vie qui
sont nécessaires pour avoir des données
environnementales les plus réalistes
possibles et là on est prêt à travailler
avec les filières justement pour pouvoir
produire plus de mines environnementale
et disposer d'un corpus technique
suffisant pour justement asseoir les
scénarios de fin de vie qui vont
caractériser ces matériaux donc la dh
super a engagé des travaux avec les
professionnels de la construction et les
industriels et des matériaux biosourcés
pour identifier les freins les freins
réglementaires liés à l'utilisation de
ces matériaux une certain nombre
d'actions et des défis l'hymne est un
groupe de travail liée à l'incendié a
été créé ces carrés bâtis qui anime ce
groupe et qui s'appuie sur le cstb et le
cerib pour formaliser en fait un
programme de travail déterminer en fait
les essais qu'il faudrait mener pour
mieux comprendre le comportement au feu
des matériaux biosourcés et appréhender
les performances de sorte à apporter les
justifications réglementaires
nécessaires
y at il des freins à l'utilisation des
matériaux biosourcés quand vous êtes
maître d'oeuvre ou entreprises
quand vous appliquez une technique vous
devez vérifier si cette technique et en
technique courante ou pas au niveau du
classement des assurances donc si elle
est en technique courante vous n'avez
pas à faire de déclaration particulière
à votre assureur si par contre vous
utilisez un produit ou une technique
n'est pas classé en technique par votre
assureur vous devez lui en discuter
c'est une question de gré à gré avec
votre assureur
mais ceci la même chose que vous soyez
pour un matériaux biosourcés ou un
matériau traditionnel à partir du moment
où il n'est pas prêt en technique
courante par votre assureur à la
question de savoir si l'utilisation des
matériaux biosourcés peut être
impossible vis-à-vis du risque incendie
et bien la réponse est bien évidemment
non il ya toujours des solutions
constructives pour permettre
l'utilisation des bio sourcés ce soit
des calfeutrement des plaques de
protection des parements des système
d'obturation de lame d'air
etc vous avez un site internet donc le
site de l'agencé qualité construction où
vous allez voir la liste verte de la cdp
qui vous donnera notamment tous les avis
techniques classé en liste verte sont
donc considérés en technique courante
par les assureurs et donc ne présentent
pas de risques aggravés pour
l'utilisation de ce type de produits et
demain aujourd'hui on constate en fait
que les maîtres à l'eau ils sont en
pleine évolution
on est à peu près à une évolution au
moins sur les isolants amont à des
chiffres plus précis de 10 % par an
depuis quatre ans donc le marché se
porte très bien même un essai des
batteries qui sont de plus en plus
utilisés justement parce que ça répond à
une demande un peu sociétal déjà et puis
aussi à l'évolution de la réglementation
et à des contraintes aussi con et
d'industriels d'aller vers davantage de
produits environnementaux les matériaux
biosourcés ont toutes leur leur carte à
jouer dans cette réglementation qui est
en train de se construire avec les
acteurs avec les industriels puisque
demain on engage une expérimentation et
la mise en place d'un observatoire on va
pouvoir avoir des retours terrain sur
les outils d'analysé cycle de vie qu'ont
apporté un référentiel énergie carbone
mais aussi d'être niveau de performance
qu'on a commencé à dessiner des niveaux
à atteindre notamment sur l'acte de
construire sur le volet carbone
on sait bien qu'ils eux ils ont une
empreinte carbone plutôt bonne mais
aussi sur plein de critères qui demain
viendront se rajouter comme des
indicateurs qui seront regardées dans le
cas de de cette préfiguration de la
réglementation les indicateurs liés à
l'épuisement des ressources les
indicateurs liés à la production de
déchets et à l'épuisement de l'eau là on
est sur les matériaux biosourcés très
compétitif vis-à-vis de d autres
solutions possibles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nature et galles futur des haltes dans
nos villes
50 à 70 % de la masse d'oxygène sur
terre et produite par les algues et les
micro algues les microalgues sont des
micro organismes qui se développe dans
l'eau douce ou loups de mer c'est ce
qu'on appelle aussi le phytoplancton
elles ont la capacité comme les plantes
terrestres de réaliser la photosynthèse
c'est à dire de transformer le co2 en
oxygène et en biomasse la culture des
microalgues est en plein développement
pourquoi ne pas l'intégrer à nos villes
en imaginant des bâtiments beaucoup plus
intelligent toutes les 10 à 24
vous allez avoir une division cellulaire
et une cellule mère va devenir de
cellules filles et c'est comme ça
qu'elles vont se développer ça va se
répéter ad vitam aeternam et croître
dans leurs milieux de culture xt est une
agence d'architecturé qui s'est
intéressé à la culture des microalgues
parce qu'elle s'intéresse avant tout à
penser à une ville plus durable
en associant le vivant à noville à nos
habitants
les façades d'immeubles représente un
potentiel solaire inexploité pour
deschamps verticaux finalement pour de
l'agriculture verticale et on peut
effectivement y cultiver des micro
algues qui elles ont besoin de beaucoup
de soleil pour se développer qu'en xt ui
venu nous voir ou laboratoire gpa
sachant pour travailler sur la culture
de micro hague depuis assez longtemps
ils nous ont proposé justement ce projet
d'intégrer les cultures d'algues à des
bâtiments et anna secoue fallait penser
verticale en milieu urbain le
laboratoire du gpu ea a donc mis au
point un photobioréacteurs il s'agit
d'une sorte d'aquarium ouli micro à et
de pouce dans une lame d'eau de quelques
centimètres d'épaisseur comprise entre
deux parois de verre
cette innovation appelé bio façade
permet de mieux bénéficier du
rayonnement solaire que dans des bassins
elle assure une productivité de 2 à 5
fois supérieure
on a d'un côté la culture d'algues qui
ont besoin également de co2 à un
bâtiment va générer du co2 par exemple
par des chaudières et des nutriments qui
peuvent aussi apporter par les effluents
liquides du bâtiment qui ont besoin de
lumière donc sur les façades on à la
lumière al'inverse vous avez un bâtiment
qui a aussi des besoins par exemple de
régulation thermique de chauffage ou de
refroidissement
vraiment c'est l'interaction entre les
deux qui est l'originalité majeur et
l'innovation majeure du système
effectivement on est dans une approche
totalement métabolique du bâtiment il ya
plus de déchets véritablement tout ce
qui est émis par le bâtiment par les
humains par l'activité humaine pourrait
être valorisé beaucoup mieux et à ce
titre servir effectivement une
agriculture d'un nouveau genre votre
système de culture de micro elle va
devenir intéressant pour l'industrie des
microalgues par rapport à un système
classique parce que vous allez pouvoir
produire sur toute l'année grâce à la
symbiose thermique vous allez pouvoir
diminuer les consommations énergétiques
on peut imaginer une ville du futur qui
devient improductives qui produit une
biomasse utile pour la santé la
cosmétique la nutrition c'est
intéressant pour l'alimentation animale
par exemple mais aussi humaine quand en
complément alimentaire pour la santé oms
va aussi pouvoir en extraire des
produits d'intérêts comme des piments
pour la cosmétique des antioxydants et
on va également retrouver à l'intérieur
des micros à des composés qui vont
peut-être faire ce qu'on appelle la
chimie verte vallée molécules de demain
qui vont pouvoir remplacer au fur et à
mesure la pétrochimie pour faire par
exemple des bioplastiques ou des
matériaux de ce type là on sait que dans
l'ombre globalement sur nos bâtiments
50% des façades ensoleillé ne sont pas
valorisées donc on pourrait imaginer
à l'avenir des villes productive des
villes ou sur toutes les façades
on pourrait cultiver des microalgues
demain les imams de nos villes ne seront
pas tous verts même si les micros règles
sont globalement vers les couleurs de
ses façades vont être change entre vont
évoluer même d'un jour sur l'autre en
fonction d'eux des procédés de culture
on va utiliser les microalgues sont dans
les océans
l'un des principaux puits de captation
du carbone de la planète
si on développe et demain très largement
ce système d'algos culture vertical une
bio façade pourrait capter 3 à 5 fois
plus de co2 que les espaces verts de nos
villes
[Musique]
nature et galles futur
comme un poisson dans l'eau lorsque l'on
observe le déplacement des espèces
marines
on constate qu'après des millions
d'années d'évolution l'efficacité de
leur nage provient de leur mode de
propulsion ondulatoire pour se mouvoir
ces espèces propage une onde le long de
leur corps de la tête vers la queue
générant ainsi une force physique qui
les fait avancer
il n'y a donc pas de turbine ou des
listes dans le monde marin l'anguille
par exemple est le modèle naturel le
plus performant de nage à la fois rapide
et souple et tous les poissons sont
capables de s'adapter aux contraintes
qu'ils subissent dans les courants ce
mouvement naturel est aujourd'hui une
nouvelle source d'innovation pour
produire de l'énergie
la membrane et l'énergie est vraiment
bien une meetic
on a l'impression quand on la voit
bouger dans le bassin de voir une en
glisser déplacer sur le fond donc c'est
un mouvement d'ondulation qui a été
imaginé pour récupérer de l'énergie
elle est composée d'un squelette en
carbone époxy qui va donner sa rigidité
à la structure et elle est recouverte
d'une peau d'une membrane en caoutchouc
qui va capter la pression du fluide et
déformé le squelette
donc on à l'énergie cinétique du fluide
qui va arriver sur la membrane qui
valent à déformer
moi je travaille essentiellement sur le
comportement de la membrane sur quels
paramètres on peut jouer pour qu'elles
se déforme mieux donc il ya une plus
grande courbure et ainsi qu'on puisse
récupérer plus d'énergie et une fois
qu'elle est déformé on a un système
assez simple de bobines éléments qui
vont être en mouvement relatif l'un par
rapport à l'autre et donc si ce
mouvement là qui crèvent électricité ces
convertisseurs électriques sont un peu
comme les muscles des poissons des tests
sur un prototype un sixième dans un
bassin générateur de courant de
l'ifremer à boulogne sur mer mais
également des tests sur des modèles
numériques ont permis de valider la
production d'électricité de cette future
hydroliennes donc on sort en rivière ou
en mer on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
types de courants et les même intensité
alors nos tests numérique tous
permettent de tester une large gamme de
paramètres et ainsi pouvoir optimiser le
mouvement en fonction du courant qu'on a
on peut s'adapter en termes de
déformation de la membrane notamment
avec les convertisseurs qui sont
réglables et ajustable en fonction du
courant donc hydroliennes et l'énergie
est vraiment fait pour tous les courants
que ce soit océanique fusion ou de marée
sa capacité à fonctionner dans des
courants marins à partir de 1 mètre par
seconde permet d'installer cette
hydrolienne dans mille fois plus de
lieux que les hydroliennes existantes et
dans de très nombreux fleuves partout
dans le monde
on travaille pour limiter l'impact
environnemental
donc on a déjà un mouvement qui est
assez fluide et qui ne perturbe pas de
front les courants donc ça déjà c'est un
atout majeur et ensuite on travaille
aussi sur tout ce qui est caoutchouc et
matériaux pour est fier d'être un
maximum respectueux de l'environnement
cette hydrolienne innovantes
inspirée de la nature peut fonctionner
24 heures sur 24
elle représente la promesse d'une
énergie durable plus propre et moins
chère elle pourrait être installé dans
de nombreux pays en voie de
développement qui ne sont pas encore
raccordés à un réseau électrique
[Musique]
de retour en plateau avec du coup
bertrand au lion vers du coussin et jean
paul van der linden pour décrypter ce
pca haute et je me tourner directement
vers vous le nom peut-être en effrayer
certains pca ets que vous pouvez vous
expliquer en quoi consiste ce plan donc
va se doter saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'ici la fin de l'année 2018 véronique
houssin oui donc le plan climat énergie
territorial c'est un document cadre donc
c'est une obligation pour les
collectivités de la taille de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
ça se met en place comme beaucoup de
documents cas c'est à dire qu'on a trois
phases
à l'issue de ces trois phases on aura
donc un plan d'action ce plan d'action
et comportera des fiches qui se
comportait pas uniquement par
l'agglomération mais également par
certaines communes qui le souhaitent par
des associations par des entreprises le
but c'est d'avoir des actions qui soient
les plus transversale possible et qui
touche le maximum de thématiques
possible le plan climat énergie
territorial c'est ça peut toucher et les
transports et les circuits courts
alimentaires tout ce qui concerne le
bâti donc quand on parle de bâti tout on
est touché que ce soit les habitants que
ce soit les entreprises ou les
collectivités
l'objectif c'est de mettre en place des
mesures pour revenir pour aider la
france à respecter ses engagements
climatiques qui sont de 2 40% de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre 32 %
d'énergies renouvelables c'est soutenir
on va dire la france dans cette démarche
là oui soutenir la france et puis
également être en accord avec le schéma
régional climat air énergie parce que
c'est la région qui est chef de file à
le but c'est vraiment que chaque action
puisse participer à réduire donc les gaz
à effet de serre développement des
énergies renouvelables
et puis une qualité de vie sur le
territoire et qui soit la meilleure
possible pour les usagers
bertrand guillon en cours d'élaboration
de ce plan là mais quel type de mesures
par exemple pourraient être mises en
place quels types de normes on pourrait
voir le jour à saint quentin en yvelines
est ce qu on pourrait avoir par exemple
des les éoliennes implantées à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est c'est une
image qui peut marquer qui peut faire
sourire mais c'est l'un des objectifs de
ce ce pc arrêté la production à la
consommation des énergies renouvelables
le pce teva partir d'un diagnostic et
notamment un diagnostic sur nos
capacités en termes d'indépendance
énergétique
aujourd'hui on en est pas à savoir si on
va planter telles éoliennes ou si on va
utiliser plutôt des réseaux de chaleur
etc
tout ça est dans un diagnostic est en
cours de finalisation
l'objectif bien entendu est vraiment
d'avoir dans ce pci tdd des chiffres qui
qui seront justement atteignable et en
objectifs vraiment d'atteindre comme 40
% de diminution des émissions de co2
comme justement l'objectif très
ambitieux de 32 % d'énergies
renouvelables le tout c'est que au
niveau de notre territoire on trouve les
meilleures possibilités des énergies
renouvelables c'est peut-être pas
forcément l'éolien en fonction de
certaines contraintes environnementales
des espaces aussi disponibles au delà de
l'environnement urbain c'est peut-être
plus tôt les réseaux de chaleur par
rapport aux premiers éléments qu'on
trouve de cette étude sur de ce
diagnostic sur les énergies
c'est peut-être également sur un petit
peu de solaire par rapport à l'ensemble
du bâti qui existe tout ça doit vraiment
nous porter sur des éléments concrets de
mise en place
il est hors de question qu'on est
aujourd'hui un pc a été qu'ils soient
uniquement un plan qu'on se dise de
toute nation c'est pour 2030 2050 sans
sera d'autres non il faut qu'on puisse
mettre en place ces objectifs concrets
dès maintenant est-ce que c'est exagéré
de dire que c'est un peu notre accord
sur le climat local ça parle ça parle
beaucoup l'accord sur le climat est ce
qu'on peut dire que ça sera l'accord
climat de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
thorn et coussins ou alors les mecs
c'est exagéré comme expression l'accord
climat c'est peut-être l'accord qui est
un petit peu fort en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est ce plan c'est
quelque chose qui doit faire lire qui
doit faire sens pour tous donc anako oui
entre tous pour que tous puissent mettre
en place une action que ce soit chez soi
où que ce soit au niveau de son travail
dans son mode de transport
habitudes de vie les modes de vie
s'appuie bien sûr bien sûr le la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre ou la
mise en place des énergies renouvelables
tu sois dans son habitat ou sur le
bâtiment son entreprise c'est un
changement de mode de vie la sobriété
énergétique
la diminution des consommations
énergétiques c'est un c'est un
changement de mode de vie c'est quelque
chose qui est très important donc un
accord oui un accord entre tous je pense
qu'on peut parler d'accord dans ce cadre
là jean paul van der linden ça permet de
replacer un peu les choses aussi ce
débat cette discussion de voir que
finalement le réchauffement climatique
on a peut-être l'impression que ce sont
uniquement les décideurs politiques
économiques qui ont la main là dessus
mais finalement le local aussi à une
part à jouer
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler
lui dire à quel point c'est important le
local dans le réchauffement climatique
alors ce qui est ce qui est fantastique
avec un dispositif comme le pc a été
c'est que c'est une question de
changement de mode de vie mais c'est
aussi une question d'augmentation
qualité de vie localement et ça on doit
se rappeler que la lutte contre les
changements climatiques ce n'est pas que
se priver si aussi améliorer un
développement économique mais centré sur
une transition économique vers
l'économie verte
c'est aussi se préparer à différentes
échelles de temps pour s'adapter car le
changement climatique aura lieu nous
devons faire des efforts mais il aura
lieu il a déjà lieu aujourd'hui je
travaille dans des endroits qui en sont
qui en vivent
le choc et donc se préparer est aussi
important qu'atténuer et se préparer ça
veut dire bea
quand je me déplace à vélo jeu
j'augmente la santé générale je diminue
mon poids ce qui est agréable toute une
série de choses positives
arrivé en même temps j'étais nu et en
même temps je deviens plus fort pour
faire face aux changements à venir et
donc dans ce dispositif pca et éthique
et très innovant je suis assez fier
d'être en france pour ça c'est un
dispositif qui touche la qualité de vie
de façon transverse et localement et qui
permet aussi peut-être de répondre à des
besoins ou des taux voire territoriaux
qui ne sont pas les mêmes à l'échelle
d'un pays par exemple convient d'une
ville côtière où d'une ville dans en
ile-de-france feu oui exactement il ya
un exemple que j'aime beaucoup c'est par
exemple les corps de métiers il va y
avoir un changement dans la nature des
corps de métier aujourd'hui
si vous voulez vous chauffez
vertueusement vous avez du mal ça existe
nous faisait du mal à trouver un
chauffagiste et gala est une opportunité
à saisir car une série de personnes
feront une transition privé un titre
personnel mais devront embaucher des
gens parlent à faire et ça typiquement
une politique locale une politique
territorialisée peut faire la différence
et peut même donner un avantage
compétitif à certains territoires qui
prendront de l'avant sur d'autres un
bertrand guillon jean paul vendeurs les
donnes parler du fait que le changement
climatique pour que donc ça parle
peut-être aux citoyens c'est aussi de
faire passer le message que ce n'est pas
uniquement des privations et c'est aussi
un gain pour soi personnel est-ce que
c'est aussi le but faire de la pédagogie
pour que le les citoyens adhèrent et le
tissu local adhèrent à ce à ce projet à
ce plan climat énergie territorial
la sensibilisation est particulière
importante sur les transports
transformation des modes de vie mais je
pense aujourd'hui pour avoir eu
l'occasion de rencontrer un certain
nombre d'acteurs du territoire notamment
acteurs associatifs et puis habitants
pour pouvoir partager discuter très
régulièrement avec un certain nombre le
changement de de considération par
rapport aux changements climatiques est
aujourd'hui en train de rentrer dans les
moeurs
maintenant il va falloir à ces
événements selon vous ça fait quelques
années que c'est en train de se faire
maintenant il va falloir passer à
l'action
mais pour pouvoir passer à l'action il
est important qu en tant que
collectivité on puisse aussi montrer
l'exemple montré l'exemple ford au
bâtiment par exemple montrer l'exemple
sur les modes de transport qui sont
disponibles sur les aménagements qui
peuvent être faits en terme d'habitat en
termes de rapprochement habitat emploie
tous ces éléments là doivent aussi
justement nous permettre d'accompagner
cette transformation qui doit être aussi
une transformation individuel
aujourd'hui un habitant qui ce qui se
dit je vais aller à mon travail à vélo
par exemple on l'entend pas forcément de
manière très régulière dans notre
territoire on trouve toujours le fait
qu' il pleut souvent qu'il y a des côtes
et puis qu'il n'ya pas d'aménagements
cyclables ou qu'il n'y a pas de lieu de
stationnement
tout le monde a un rôle à jouer les
coller tout le monde essaie ça vraiment
l'objectif de ce plan c'est que
tous les acteurs tout le monde des
acteurs de ce plan là c'était déjà le
cas sur le précédent puisque on avait un
précédent plan depuis 2000 13 à 7
ça a permis de lier les différents
acteurs qui sont présents les
entreprises les collectivités des
habitants les associations
aujourd'hui on va pouvoir passer tout le
monde se connaît on va pouvoir
maintenant passer sur ce nouveau plan à
des actions plus concrètes en termes
d'aménagement en termes d'accompagnement
en termes d'innovation il ya d'autres
sujets sains pour la réduction de
l'impact climatique local il ya par
exemple les éclairages publics c'est un
c'est un enjeu important localement il
ya aussi la réduction des déchets tout
le monde peut peut agir et puis l'an
passé l'agglomération avait avait lancé
une consultation numérique auprès des
auprès des habitants pour aussi
j'imagine intéresser les habitants à à
ce plan là qu'en est il ressorti est ce
que est ce que vous sentez localement un
intérêt pour ce sujet la véronique au
sein oui donc la concertation numérique
c'était pour nous quelque chose d très
important justement pour avoir le retour
donc des habitants et des usagers du
territoire puisque il ya aussi beaucoup
de personnes qui viennent travailler sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
cette concertation nous a permis de voir
qu'il y avait déjà des actions que
beaucoup d'actions ont été mises en
place à titre personnel on part pas de
zéro ce n'est pas du tout part pas de
zéro après les thématiques qui sont
ressortis sont toujours à peu près les
mêmes c'est à dire que l'importance de
la mise en place de transports doux donc
on est toujours sur un changement
d'habitude comme le dit monsieur
houillon touski économie circulaire tout
ce qui est la possibilité de se nourrir
de produits locaux
donc ça ça fait aussi partie des actions
qui peuvent eux qui vont être mises en
place dans le cadre localement par
exemple principe locale au vendeur local
ne peut pas se nourrir entièrement
localement cependant oui on a des
possibilités de se nourrir localement
quand on parle de local on est sur un
rayon de 150 kilomètres donc on est
quand même quand même assez large mais
c'est possible aussi la concertation et
nous a aussi fait des propositions c'est
à dire que dans le cadre de cette
concertation est une question c'était
qu'est ce que vous feriez sur le
territoire pour s'adapter au changement
climatique
donc il ya aussi eu un certain nombre de
propositions qui ressort sortie est ce
que vous avez
exemple peut être un ou deux à nous à
nous donner qui vous ont marqués vous
qui sont revenus en masse alors bye à
tout ce qui est qui peut être paraître
pour certaines personnes somme toute
logique mais tout ce qui est donc
sobriété énergétique participé à ddd
commandes et l'électricité qu'on peut
appeler verte donc c'est vrai qu'on
entend plus en plus parler mais être
participer financièrement pour qui les
nouvelles sources d'énergie qu'ils
puissent être mais c'est en place sur le
territoire
donc ça on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
une volonté de pouvoir travailler
ensemble et qui est d accord avec les
différents acteurs du territoire pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
donc le but vous le disiez c'est d'ici
la fin de l'année d'avoir un plan
d'action de mettre en place des actions
locales pour ça il faut faire un
diagnostic vous l'évoquez berton riom es
ce que vous avez déjà commencé à le
faire puisque vous pouvez ressortir
quelques idées majeures de ce ce
diagnostic est ce qu'on est sur un
territoire
j'ai envie de dire éco-responsable ce
qu'il ya de grosses faiblesses de
grosses qualités déjà à saint quentin en
yvelines comme les déchets au lion les
diagnostics est en cours de finalisation
et sa valise et compliqué pas de vous
donner tout l'ensemble de ce qui ressort
mais c'est vrai qu'on a dans le cadre du
plan climat on a des obligations
d'études donc des outils d'obligatoire
par rapport à la vulnérabilité du
territoire par rapport justement au
développement des énergies renouvelables
eau aux émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et puis c'est vrai que saint
quentin a voulu aller plus loin dans le
cadre du diagnostic donc nous on
s'appuie aussi sur le conseil de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines
kim qui fait part aussi de son retour
sur le diagnostic
on s'appuie aussi donc sur la
concertation numérique et puis on
s'appuie aussi sur les autres plans
cadre de saint-quentin tels que le
projet de territoire où il ya aussi eu
un diagnostic
le but c'est d'avoir le maximum de
retours et d'information pour proposer
une stratégie et un plan d'action qui en
découlent qui soit vraiment quelque
chose qui réponde aux attentes et qui
soit localement faisable c'est très
important de voir que plus on avait
planté territoire différentes et que ce
qui est possible à 51 n'est pas
obligatoirement possible sur un
territoire même de région ile de france
on a des problématiques qui sont
différentes mais on a aussi des atouts
qui sont différents donc le but c'est
bien de s'appuyer sur ces est tous là
pour lever les obstacles et pour voir
affaire de saint-quentin donc un
territoire le plus en adéquation avec
l'adaptation aux changements climatiques
jean paul van der linden vous en tant
que spécialistes de ces sujets là vous
êtes professeur à lui est ce qu un
membre de l'observatoire de versailles
saint quentin davy vous êtes aussi amené
à beaucoup voyager sur les aides pour
répondre à ces à ces sujets climatique
et quel regard vous vous portez sur les
sur les besoins de ce territoire là de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être mise en place localement
qu'est ce qui est faisable en
agglomération parisienne par exemple
plutôt que de parler besoin je vais
d'abord parlé de force parce que c'est
très important la première chose et je
pense que la consultation numérique
parle de ça aussi c'est l'incroyable
compétences qui sont présentes sur le
territoire
on a à la fois une population de
personnes qui travaillent ici et de
personnes qui vivent ici qui sont très
éduquée est prête à agir
donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'absolument fantastique pour un
territoire ça veut dire qu'il peut
avancer
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de
besoin mais ça veut dire que les besoins
sont qualitativement différent et que
l'interfaçage avec la population peut
être plus facile plus difficile selon
les enjeux
la deuxième chose c'est évidemment et là
je pourrais je prends ma chapelle à la
présence de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à saint
quentin qui est quelque chose de
fabuleux indépendamment du fait que cela
manque l'os
cela apporte une expertise dans laquelle
les gens pioche et je parle de mes
collègues mes étudiants et stagiaires il
ya là quelque chose de très très utiles
dans le cadre d'un plan transverses d'un
plan qui touche tous les secteurs de la
connaissance tous les secteurs
d'économie bien on a une université
pluridisciplinaire qui est là et qui
peut se mettre au service du territoire
alors les besoins là la question de
l'autonomie énergétique est une question
très compliquée je pense au niveau des
besoins nous sommes un territoire keith
urban
id et c'est normal c'est la tendance la
population se concentre en ile de france
et ça ça a du bon mais ans urbanisant
les opportunités de libération d'
espaces pour de la production d'énergie
bien elle diminue et donc il faut
arriver à trouver un moyen de je dirais
de faire ce qu'on appelle une transition
énergétique mais une transition
énergétique qui ne vient pas brider les
possibilités du territoire s'est pas
seulement l'histoire de traitement de
jouer sur les deux c'est vrai que l'on
pourra aussi faire réagir bertrand
guillon là dessus mais on est sur un
territoire où l'innovation l'économie
est souvent mise en avant est ce que ça
c'est vraiment faisable en ayant des
contraintes environnementales
importantes déjà monsieur van der linden
et puis alors je vous donne un exemple
simple de deux d'innovation de
gouvernance tant qu'on ne parle pas
d'innovations technologiques mais la
technologie joue un rôle par exemple
l'installation de capteurs réellement
intelligent qui parle à nos structures
techniques à nos politiques et qui en
temps réel dresse un diagnostic déjà ça
ça permet de shift et le poids de la
production vers une plus grande
frugalité au niveau de la consommation
sans que ce soit nécessairement
frustrant et aujourd'hui la technologie
nous permet de récolter 7 données en
temps réel pour informer en temps réel
le décideur donc là on a déjà quelque
chose qui je pense pour pour notre
territoire est assez prometteur la
deuxième chose c'est les micros
production décentralisée et ça c'est
tout un défi
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
peut-être pour ceux qui ne sont pas
spécialement un sujet dont moi je suis
pas très très compétent sur les
techniques mais je pense que le
photovoltaïque a malheureusement eu un
pic
et puis un certain désintérêt un peu dia
la fiscalité avec les marches avant et
des marches arrière qui a eu lieu mais
il ya quelque chose à travailler là
dessus il ya tout ce qui est travail sur
la méthanisation on a encore des
producteurs agricoles ici on a encore
des déchetteries des choses qui nous
permettent de produire d'énergie à
partir du méthane qui est un produit de
la décomposition de la matière organique
dans les déchets a et là j'arrive au
bout de ce que j'imaginais mais
j'imagine que des gens qui pour vous
répondre mieux que moi là dessus
bertrand au lion sur 7
problématique que j'ai soulevées sur
l'intérêt économique important depuis de
nombreuses années à saint quentin en
yvelines et sur le développement durable
urbanisation est ce que tout ça on peut
compilé tout ça ou alors un moment il va
falloir freiner quelque part pour
pouvoir respecter ses futurs engagements
environnementaux
aujourd'hui le monde de l'entreprise
s'engage aussi dans dans ces questions
de transition
on a un club qui m'a énergie qui existe
depuis justement le précédent plan à
saint quentin en yvelines et qui permet
d'avoir des discussions entre
entreprises des partages d'expérience
mais aussi avec nos collectivités et
et on s'aperçoit que sur notre
territoire
on a aussi cette expertise économique
cette expertise en terme d'innovation
pour pour aider notre territoire en
transition tout ça il faut qu'on puisse
l'utiliser
il faut que les entreprises qui sont
présentes sur le territoire de saint
quentin utilise aussi le territoire pour
pouvoir mettre en pratique ses
innovations
on dit souvent que saint quentin en
yvelines est un territoire d'innovation
justement prouvons le en mettant
l'ensemble de de ses compétences
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines en termes de recherche les les
entreprises du territoire en terme
d'application les les start up qui
existe sur notre territoire sont une
véritable richesse et puis ensuite les
associations les habitants ont aussi ont
aussi un certain nombre d'idées de mise
en application d'utilisation des espaces
publics je prends un exemple qui peut
paraître tout simple sur la remise de la
nature dans les territoires ça doit nous
permettre aussi de de commencer à
transformer notre territoire pour
pouvoir nous adapter par rapport aux
changements climatiques le fait de
remettre des arbres dans dans les villes
le fait de lutter contre ces ces zones
là je ne suis pas expert mais ces zones
particulièrement chaude par rapport par
rapport au béton dans des villes sens
c'est en elle jure il faut qu'on remette
du végétal dans les villes aujourd'hui
on a des associations d'habitants qui
plantent des arbres dans nos communes
c'est ça peut paraître rien mais en fait
c'est énorme par rapport à notre à notre
obligation nous adapter aux changements
qui va y avoir et les jardins partagés a
aussi qui sont désignés et il ya ces
jardins partagés par rapport à la
consommation locale
on évoquait la production locale de de
nourriture ce retour de l'agriculture
directement auprès des territoires
urbains ou dans les territoires urbains
c'est aussi un enjeu par rapport à
l'alimentation locale et on a un projet
alimentaire qui qui est sur notre
territoire avec versailles grand parc et
paris saclay qu'il faut qu'on puisse
aussi mettre en oeuvre il sera intégré
dans dans ce plan climat air énergie
vous parliez de versailles grand parc
session parfaite transition se renier
coussin parce que même si c'est un plan
qui ça va s'appliquer à saint quentin en
yvelines les gaz à effet de serre n'ont
pas de frontières est-ce que vous
travaillez avec les autres collectivités
aussi pour peut-être vous accorder sur
sur des plans d'action plus globaux le
projet alimentaire territoriale est un
très bon exemple par un par rapport à
cette collaboration nous il y en effet
bien sûr on travaille moi je travaille
en lien avec donc mes homologues qui
sont sur la communauté paris saclay et
versailles grand parc
le but c'est ayant des territoires qui
somme toute ont une forme similaire même
si on n'a pas la même histoire on est
quand même des territoires périurbains
et donc de ce fait non on a quand même
des problématiques qui sont qui sont
similaires
donc le but c'est de pouvoir échanger
avoir un partage d'expériences avoir un
partage aussi en termes d'actions et le
projet alimentaire territoriale est
vraiment un projet sur lequel nous
travaillons ensemble pour pouvoir tendre
à une à mettre en place des circuits
courts alimentaires sur le ce territoire
qui est beaucoup plus vaste parce que le
but c'est de pouvoir justement faciliter
les échanges et puis réduire aussi ce
projet alimentaire territoriales c'est
aussi le retour de l'alimentation plus
locale mais c'est aussi donc réduire les
émissions parce que plus on fait de
transfert d'alimentaire plus il ya des
émissions là le but c'est en ramenant au
look
on réduit les émissions donc c'est un
vrai cercle vertueux alesi et serait
aussi un développement économique
puisque qui dit qu'on rapproche le la
partie production alimentaire dit aussi
qu'il va falloir transformer ses
productions alimentaires et donc qui dit
transformation 10 emplois pour le faire
et c'est des emplois moment donné qui ne
sont pas délocalisables
c'est la même chose par rapport à tout
ce qui est obsolescence par rapport à la
réparation par exemple de
l'électroménager on a sur le territoire
d un secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui aujourd'hui investi sur
ces recycleurs i say say possibilité de
réparation d'outils d'outils du
quotidien la machine à laver etc
je pense a envie qui est sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
ce sont des acteurs majeurs aussi pour
pouvoir emmener cette nouvelle forme
d'économie qui permet d'avoir cette ces
circuits courts et cette durabilité par
rapport à la vie quotidienne des
habitants alors une peut-être d'un
question avant de conclure cette
émission sur peut-être le coup que ça de
mettre en place une politique
environnementale ambitieuse on sait que
c'est un peu le malheureusement encore
et ça le sera encore très longtemps
le nerf de la guerre l'argent public
mise à disposition on en a de moins en
moins un jean paul van der linden et
excuse c'est un coût important
une politique environnementale
ambitieuse ou alors comme vous le disiez
ça peut être un coup mais aussi des
gains vous disiez tout à l'heure par
rapport aux contraintes il faut pas voir
ça uniquement comme des contraintes
comme un gain potentiel personnel est ce
que ça peut être aussi des rentrées
financières nouvelles oui alors c'est
une question un peu piège mais il ya
deux niveaux de réponse le premier
niveau de réponse et qu'une meilleure
coordination de l'action publique qui
m'a air énergie territoire ces icônes
hommes ce qui est coûteux c'est lorsque
l'action publique est segmenté fragmenté
lorsque les gens ne se parlent pas or
avec le plan climat air énergie
territorial on se lance dans une action
vertueuse économe
donc je sais que je ne répond pas à
votre question précisément mais les
accusés qui sont importantes sur les
coûts dans les accords internationaux
c'est l'une des hausses idée
importante problématique à chaque fois
c'est la mise en place de fonds de fonds
verts vont soutenir les territoires les
plus pauvres est-ce que local en la mise
en place de fonds vers ça m'intéresse
parce qu'il ya une dimension financière
aussi c'est à dire qu'en fait-on face au
court qu'en fait-on face aux bénéfices
et la vision politique c'est
effectivement d'accepter d'investir
aujourd'hui pour récolter les fruits
demain et d'accepter que ce demain ne
soit pas le demain de l'échéancier des
élections mais que ce soit le demain de
l'échéancier de naissance de nos enfants
de nos petits-enfants dépendante de
janeiro admiration et donc sont toutes
ces couches n'est pas tant une question
de coût net
c'est plutôt une question d' analyse
coûts bénéfices sur le long terme et
c'est à des analyses coûts-bénéfices est
toujours en faveur d'un certain niveau
de protection et le comprennent selon
vous je pense que les politiques locales
reprennent vers confiant je pense que la
population le comprendre et je pense que
les intérêts de très court terme ne
souhaite pas le comprendre les gens qui
ont des intérêts dans le court terme
alors bertron union se on se doute que
vous n'avez pas d'intérêt à court terme
on l'imaginé on l'espère en tout cas
c'est un peu aussi ça l'enjeu politique
il faudra voter ce plan est ce que vous
pensez que 50 on évite va se doter aussi
des moyens financiers pour avoir une
politique ambitieuse environnementale
est ce que est ce que vous vous
surveiller ça de près ce que vous êtes
la politique c'est la responsabilité
pour l'avenir à un moment donné c'est
pas des des préoccupations personnelles
d'échéances électorales
ça ne doit pas l'être et la grande
complexité par rapport aux changements
climatiques
c'est en effet nos propres personnes par
rapport aux échéances d'augmentation de
température ça nous dépasse
par contre ça dépassera pas les
générations futures et c'est là notre
responsabilité particulièrement
importante même si aujourd'hui
de temps en temps sous nos climats on
voit poindre un certain nombre de
dérèglements que parfois on nous dit ce
n'est pas vraiment ça il faut être
vigilant
c'est vraiment des choses qui peuvent
nous dépasser mais on sait et il faut
surtout pas revenir dessus aujourd'hui
on sait que de toute façon il y aura un
changement climatique aujourd'hui notre
responsabilité c'est très directement et
très concrètement sur nos territoires de
pouvoir transformer nos bâtiments en
économies d'énergie
là aussi c'est une question de
financement
c'est à dire que dans dix ans dans 15
ans déjà
ou même l'année prochaine l'évolution du
coût des énergies fossiles pour les
collectivités et donc pour l'impôt et
qu'est ce que ça va être
et bien aujourd'hui notre responsabilité
c'est de pouvoir la maîtriser le mieux
possible et donc de faire des bâtiments
qu'ils soient le plus économe possible
et ces sujets là est ce que vous sentez
que vos collègues élus avec une question
qui peut paraître très simple et pas à
la hauteur des enjeux mais même les
opposants politiques est ce que vous
sentez que c'est une question
transversale que tout le monde a compris
ou alors qu'il ya je demanderai à mes
collègues puisqu'on travaille sur le
projet de territoire et ce plan climat
air énergie est inclus dans le projet de
territoire
je leur demande de pouvoir inclure très
directement dans le projet de territoire
le fait que saint quentin en yvelines au
delà d'être un territoire d'innovation
soit justement ce territoire de
transition par rapport aux changements
climatiques qui vont avoir lieu
c'est une innovation par rapport à ce
qu'on connaissait il faut sortir du
concept années 80 on a eu une réussite
économique sur saint quentin en yvelines
on a un certain nombre de réussite en
terme de transports locaux
on sait que on n'y est pas encore
puisque 90% des habitants de la
collectivité utilisent encore la voiture
particulière donc il faut qu'on trouve
toutes les innovations possibles
ensemble pour pouvoir faire cette
transition sur saint quentin en yvelines
et forcément il faut que
l'investissement soit tourné vers ça
c'est l'investissement et c'est
l'investissement pour l'avenir qui nous
permettra derrière d'avoir un
fonctionnement qui sera vertueuse
véronique houssin rapidement pour
conclure cette émission seront sur le
calendrier
où en est on saint quentin en yvelines
devra voter ce plan avant la fin de
l'année et là où on est on concrètement
on est on tient on tient le planning
c'est toujours très compliqué de tenir
un planning sur ce type de plan parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a toujours envie
d'aller plus loin et d'avoir un
diagnostic le plus complet possible
le diagnostic est en cours de
finalisation on va voir des ateliers
définition de la stratégie territoriale
donc pour prioriser les actions à moyen
et à court moyen et long terme
et puis donc
1 prend un programme d'action qui va
être mis en place courant mai donc dans
ce cadre là l'ensemble des acteurs
seront seront invités à venir participer
aux ateliers donc les associations les
acteurs économiques les collectivités du
territoire pour pouvoir définir les
actions et puis aussi pour pouvoir se
porter mêmes acteurs mais vraiment
pilote de fiches actions du plan climat
s'est pas uniquement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines communauté
d'agglomération qui sera pilote mais
c'est aussi des acteurs qui peuvent être
pilote d'action est on est on aimerait
beaucoup pouvoir mettre en place une
charte des acteurs du plan climat
justement aussi pour aller vers cette
innovation de gouvernance cette
innovation de deux modes de travail
ensemble
et puis un vote proposé au conseil
communautaire de 7 ans et puis pour
l'ensemble des habitants du cou et des
acteurs dont vous parliez il y a plus
d'informations disponibles sur le site
internet de l'agglomération sky point fr
et puis aussi sur le site internet de
l'ademe merci à vous d'être venu en
plateau pour six numéros du 7-8 société
consacré donc à la mise en place à saint
quentin en yvelines à saint quentin en
yvelines d'un plan climat air énergie et
eaux territoriales un enjeu on l'aura
bien compris important pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique d'un
point de vue local si vous souhaitez
avoir plus d'information du coup rendez
vous sur sky point fr ou sur le site
internet de l'ademe
merci encore à vous on se retrouve
bientôt pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8
sociétés
[Musique]